[Music]
in may a rare case of monkey box a virus
closely related to smallpox was
diagnosed in the uk that first uk case
which was from a traveler in nigeria is
now thought to be unconnected to the
wider outbreak but the uk went on quite
quickly to report many more cases today
the uk has the globe's highest monkey
pox case numbers and the viruses spread
to more than 4 500 confirmed or
suspected cases across at least 40
countries including the u.s and canada
on tuesday the cdc said they are
significantly expanding monkey pox
vaccination efforts in the u.s the
agency also said it is now recommending
vaccines for people with presumed
exposure to viral illness and not just
confirmed exposure so how serious is the
monkey pox outbreak and should americans
be concerned about contracting this
virus
last month world health organization
officials said they expected monkey pox
cases to grow but stressed the situation
was containable
this is a containable situation
particularly in the countries like where
we are seeing these outbreaks that are
happening across europe
in
north america as well this month the who
said that monkey pox doesn't at this
point constitute a global health
emergency they have said however that
they might revisit that decision
if the situation
worsens so for example if there was
evidence that people were getting more
severe disease or if there was evidence
that the virus was spreading into more
vulnerable groups like children or
people with weakened immune systems
in the u.s so far over 300 cases have
been confirmed across at least 27 states
and the district of columbia
textbook monkeybox uh typically starts
with flu-like symptoms you've got a
fever headache muscle like backache and
then a few days later you get a rash uh
normally starting on the face and
spreading out and it's a little like
chickenpox so it starts as these
flat red marks they get become kind of
pimple like but in the current outbreak
there have been lots of case reports of
pretty different looking symptoms some
people are getting no rash some people
are getting
very subtle rashes a lot of times people
are noticing a concentration of the rash
in the genital area rather than starting
in the face
scientists believe the main way
monkeyprox is spread is by close contact
previous research found that monkeypox
virus particles spread over short
distances via respiratory droplets but
it is unknown whether monkey pox can
spread by tinier airborne particles
known as aerosols so there are high
levels of virus in the like the
pus-filled lesions that the disease
causes and contact with that is thought
to be the main mode of spread monkey
pulse is much less easily spread than a
virus that can be spread easily through
the air like covered 19 would be an
obvious example um but if you are in
very close contact with someone then it
is quite easy to catch u.s health
officials found that monkey pox cases
are concentrated in specific communities
according to the cdc at least some of
the u.s cases were people who identify
as gay bisexual or men who have sex with
men the virus can impact anyone
regardless of sexuality but infectious
disease experts think that the virus is
exploiting very close contact between
some members of this community to spread
this is the first time since the hiv
epidemic of the 1980s that a newly
emerging disease has you know cropped up
and is
concentrated in this community um
one big difference between now and then
is that while public health authorities
were very slow to respond to the hiv
epidemic this time they are making a lot
of effort to get the message out to gay
and bisexual men and they're doing
things like handing out information at
pride events they're sending push
notifications on dating apps like grindr
most cases of monkeypox resolve on their
own without treatment however there are
some antiviral drugs and a vaccine that
were developed for smallpox that also
work against monkeypox
on tuesday danish vaccine maker bavaria
nordic which is the only producer of a
vaccine licensed for monkey pox said it
will meet demand it's just like a
traditional vaccine it it builds your
immune system it stimulates your immune
system so you are better prepared to
fight the
monkey parks
you are infected with monkey pox was
discovered in lab monkeys in denmark in
1958 hence the monkey in monkey pox that
said monkeys aren't thought to be the
main vector or carrier of the disease
scientists aren't totally sure what
species is the main carrier but it seems
to be very widely circulating among
certain rodents in the rainforests
of the congo basin in central africa
and the first human case was
discovered in 1970 in a nine-year-old
boy in the democratic republic of congo
in the current outbreak about four and a
half thousand people have been confirmed
with monkeypox in countries where the
virus doesn't normally occur and none of
those have died thus far there's only
been one death in nigeria
[Music]